howdy
i'm david pollock and the first thing
i'm going to talk about is
why the lab coat so there was a
twitter thing going on and
fogus was talking about i want a job
where i can wear a lab coat and then
serious pony was talking about
the difference between wearing a
turtleneck and a lab coat and my kids
love phineas and ferb who here know
phineas and ferb
yeah okay good so you know there's heinz
doofenshmirtz
and so the backstory of me wearing a lab
coat a black turtleneck
uh creased jeans and lace shoes is i
lost a bet
i'm also like absolutely obsessed with
spreadsheets i've written a couple of
commercial ones in my life and
kind of a lot of what i want to do is
kind of push business logic as close to
business users as possible and i think a
lot of what gets lost
in us as developers is the translation
of
business needs to business use cases
to designs to code
to implementation and you know there's
there's a lot of telephone there and a
lot of stuff gets lost and so kind of
the mad scientist in me
kind of wants to to bring that business
logic as close to users as possible so
you know i've been doing that with
spread or did that with spreadsheets
back in the 90s
i've been kind of trying to get back to
that place you know it's kind of like
you know
sam left the lost island and he had to
get back
it's like that so i've been doing lyft
and scala for seven years i've recently
found closure and been playing around
with that and i've got a
set of closure libraries called plu that
i've been working on
i'm also trained as a lawyer and
my brain was kind of warped that way
i recently or this week we announced
brick alloy which is a consulting firm
with me and four other people um
two of whom are lift committers one
commits to or
runs a project called dexy which is the
absolute best way to do
um documentation and a whole bunch of
other stuff
uh to take a look at it and we basically
deliver cloud systems that drive
business success
so let's get to the heart of the matter
because i have 40 minutes and i've
already wasted two of them
um so ultimately server push
is a subset of a bigger problem and the
bigger problem
is how do we how do we do stuff across
address spaces
so in computing a lot of what we look at
is stuff within
our own address space and with the
exception of
erlang almost every other language kind
of
says well you know there's my address or
there's a local address space and
there's everybody else
and there's very very little semantics
that we have
and even fewer good semantics that we
have for dealing with this stuff across
address spaces yet these days it's the
vast majority of what we do
and you know the the problem false boils
down into transport how do we get
how do we get the bits across address
spaces
marshalling what are the bits and then
the semantics of our program
so you know we've got a program running
on two sides in
two different address spaces how do we
kind of deal
appropriately with the program on either
one of those across either one of those
address spaces you know yes we can
write a rest end point for every single
thing
and we can write a rest call for every
single thing but you know that's
many many many lines of boilerplate
multiplied by many many many
other things that kind of starts really
weighing
on and unbalancing the whole software
project because it's not
you know many of our software projects
are not about the business logic
they're about the yes i'm getting back
to the business logic the bl
term it's not about the business logic
it's about the transport and it's about
the marshalling
so let's talk about transport first you
know it's like use http unless there's a
darn good reason not to
so if you're going across address spaces
you're going to be doing it with http
why because it traverses firewalls yay
and because it's got a lot of understood
semantics
and you know yeah if you're talking to
your local database unless it's react
you're going to be
using some local wire protocol and you
know if you're talking to your message
queue
it's most likely going to be over a wire
protocol but almost
anything else you want to do just use
http
the bigger issue is marshalling and you
know it's like the clown car image
because
you know marshalling data especially oo
data
is really really really
a sad silly joke um
you know if you think about why
marshalling oo data is particularly sad
and silly
it's because oo is a combination of code
and data that are supposed to kind of go
with each other
except when you're going across address
spaces they don't go with each other
and even when you know when you go
across address spaces with your code and
your data
even if you're running the same
nominally the same code across the
address spaces
at some point you're going to have
versioning problems because something in
address space a is gonna be
running version 1.2 and address space b
is running
version 1.3 so unless you actually move
the
bytes that represent the code across the
address spaces
making method invocations on your
objects after they've crossed the
address space
is wrong it doesn't work so
i think you know you really want to have
a semantic about your cross-address
space
stuff that doesn't involve code
because your code really is going to be
different across the address spaces
and so erlang really recognizes that and
but they do allow you to marshal
functions as part as a parameter in your
data but it's like special built into
beam
magic stuff that does the marshalling
nobody else has that
you know javascript we've got json why
is json become the way that we do
everything
because you know it works most of the
time it's kind of like http
yeah it does what i need it to do so
let's move on
um closure script or closure enclosure
script also have
particularly nice slightly richer
ways of marshaling data so if you're not
using erlang
or um closure
use json so the next thing is how do you
deal with your program semantics who
here has ever done j2ee
and rmi ooh good oh
no sorry too many people raised their
hand but you know it was really ugly
and the ugly thing about it was that you
didn't know
so you're making a call you're invoking
a method
on some remote thing and you know java
is all about having
mutable objects so you serialize your
mutable objects across address spaces
except some of them can't really and so
you know your remote code then mutates
something
and that mutation isn't necessarily
remoted back to you
you've got the junior developer who
doesn't understand the cost
of doing a remote call is you know many
many many orders of magnitude higher
than doing a
local method invocation so just having
very very simple
things in your code that denote a remote
endpoint versus a local endpoint is kind
of sort of valuable so you think about
scala's actors and akka actors and you
know the actor paradigm
the actor paradigm says to it's like a
big bang it's a big exclamation point
that says
this the execution characteristics of
this endpoint
are going to be different expect them to
be different
so you know you don't usually put you
don't usually have
nested within um eight levels of loops
a message send to an actor you know you
that's
the little bang there is like a little
indication that ah you know what
maybe i should collect the data up and
send it over in a larger batch rather
than having
20 000 message sends
another way of doing program semantics
which is the way that i think most of us
are used to doing them these days
is to hand roll them on every call
so you know i want to go across address
spaces so i'll just make a rest call to
my endpoint and
the rest call to my endpoint and i'll
like you know hang out there and consume
a thread or
maybe have if i'm doing node i'll have
my callback function that continues the
computation and blah blah blah blah
and you know those are syntactically
sugared with
uh the likes of futures and you know
promises and a bunch of other stuff but
at the end of the day what we have is we
have
this hand rolled per invocation
nastiness
and you know that doesn't work real well
that's not scalable once again it puts a
lot of our
programming effort and our programming
brains on the side
of okay how do i marshal this stuff how
do i
make that call rather than yes i'm
invoking a services
that's not part of my address space but
that really shouldn't be materially
harder
than dealing with something that is in
my address space
so you know we've got answers or we've
got semantics that we've tried
uh futures and actors and promises
channels cues but you know
none of them feel quite right um
and you know there's also stuff as we
marshal across http and we're starting
to get into the
the the reason for the talk is that http
it has a lot of interesting hidden
gotchas especially if you're talking
from the browser
so there's a limited number of browser
to server connections and this is to the
name
server so you know what if you've got a
bunch of rest code
in your browser let's say you've got you
know you load up a page
and the page has 14 different components
on the page and each of the 14 different
components
wants to go and recall data from the
server and get its current state and
that sort of thing
you've got 14 connections and depending
on your browser you're only allowed
between one and eight of those 14
connections
so you block and what happens when you
block well you know if you're just
blocking the other
requests that's not the worst thing in
the world but if you're blocking the
downloading of an image or more
javascript
then you've basically really hosed the
user experience
until the data is satisfied from the
server
um and you know that it usually bites
people when you go into production
because each of the individual modules
kind of sort of works the right way and
you're doing it in the local lan where
you have you know seven millisecond
response time
it all kind of you know just flows onto
your screen so when you're doing the
demo
everybody's like oh yeah that's great
but then you've got you know the
vagaries or the real internet and you've
got
um 250 millisecond latency and you've
got drop
packets and you've got um proxies that
do http retries and the proxies
themselves are unreliable so the proxy
may say that the thing failed but the
server actually
returned a response so you retry and if
your
call isn't item potent then you've just
like caused a double update and yeah
people are not in their heads going ah
yeah i remember that one
um and on top of it all you really can't
trust what's on the wire
the wire lies and part of part of my
like upbringing is security
so you as a developer when you're
writing that nice rest end point
you have to basically go okay somebody's
making a rest call
and i've got to you know make sure their
credentials are right and blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
because every single http request can be
a lie
and very many of them are
so the key goals that we want for our
cross address space stuff
is we want kind of native ish
lightweight semantics so we don't want
to go all the way over to the rmi side
of the
field which is hey you don't know
whether this is local or remote and i'm
not going to tell you
unless you go with a hungarian method
which is you know underscore remote for
every
rmi call um but at the same time you
don't want to have
eight lines of make this request here's
my promise here's what to do at the end
of my promise
and you know yada yada yada because that
code also becomes
um what is it uh call back hell or
what's the
current name for that thing um
the other thing is that we want to treat
our
inter address space requests very much
like we treat tcpip
so you know you open up a tcp connection
and you don't really know that your
packets are being split up and you don't
really know and you don't really care
when you have
retries up until a certain point what
you want is you want an ordered stream
of bytes i'm going to send you an
ordered stream of bytes i'm going to
receive an ordered stream of bytes
and most of the time i don't care
whether there are retries
most of the time i don't care whether
there are failures only when they go
above a certain threshold
should i really care and as app
developers we want the same
sort of thing when we're when we're
sending data across
address spaces yeah we want to know
there can be failures we want to be able
to deal with those failures
but in the normal course of events
that was shouldn't have been a joke in
the normal course of events we don't
want to have to
send a little chunk of data and say did
that did that get through is that okay
we want some underlying transport to be
able to deal with that
um and one of the things that i've i've
kind of
i developed with lyft early on and has
worked very very well as a globally
unique identifier so we started off with
globally unique identifiers for
functions on the server that relate to
actions in the browser
so you know you push a button in the
browser and it invokes a function on the
server and there are a whole bunch of
real nice advantages to that
one of the advantages to the globally
unique identifier is
you don't have to marshal data that's
related to the button push
into the browser because you might be
exposing data
which is a security leak you might be
giving tamperable data
which is a security problem you're also
transmitting a lot more information
over from the server to the browser than
you have to and with scala
and with closure and you know a bunch of
other languages
when you can have um a function that has
scope and the function will be
applied invoked called whatever your
function
[Music]
making happen semantics are with the
parameter that you get from the browser
so the really nice thing is that guides
are like refs
you know they're references they're
they're a pointer across address space
to that thing that you care about
without having to expose the innards
of that thing that you care about across
the wire
it's a function it's actually nice and
functional because you don't know what's
going on
inside that thing but you know that when
you apply
the guided function with the particular
parameters
something that you wanted to happen will
it also feels a lot like actors or
channels which is
you send something to an identifier and
action takes place also goods are very
very easy to serialize
yes they're just a nice happy string
the only problem or challenge with them
is that they
cause gc garbage collection problems
because you want to make sure that you
know that the guides that
are still being referred to on your web
page
shouldn't be gc'd out of memory on your
server
but once they cease to be and this
becomes a bigger issue
when you have single page applications
once they cease to be referenced
on the browser you want them to be gc'd
on the server because
you know when you have a function on the
server that closes over scope
that closure over scope is something
that retains memory
and you know if you have a list of a
thousand customer records
that is part of your function that's
going to be executed
you want to get rid of that thing as
soon as possible because you don't want
50 000 functions that close over a
thousand customer records
floating around on your server the other
thing is and this gets back
into kind of where where you have the
balance of vagaries
you want to have some sort of confirmed
delivery and delivery once
so when you send something to the server
when your application
calls that send invoke this thing
and you know you know it's being invoked
across the wire
you want to make sure that it gets there
only gets their wants
and only causes the effect once because
very very very very very very very
few operations in our
world are item potent yes gets are
nothing else is get over it
um
so in lyft we've actually done a lot of
nifty stuff
on both sides of the http transaction
where the client and the server have
both goods and clocks that are
associated with each
potential request and when the request
is sent over the wire
uh when the request is sent from the
client to the server
if the server has seen that globally
unique identified request
in the past it won't reprocess it and
what lift does is it actually keeps the
answer around
so if it gets multiple requests because
you've got a proxy in the middle and the
proxy has basically
said oh it's told the browser no i
didn't send that request the browser
retry code automatically retries yeah
lyft has a bunch of browser retry code
so the browser retry code that goes oh i
got a 500 i'm going to resend that
request
but on the other side of the world the
proxies actually sent that request over
to your application
your application has processed it so
when it gets to second request what you
want is you want the answer that was
generated the first time around
and lyft does that automatically and
under the covers it's only when there
are five retry failures
that you you get your application gets
notified that you know really something
is
i've tried this five times i've done a
logarithmic back off on
the request stuff um and you know i'm
not going to try it again i'm going to
tell you that i failed
on the server side when you want to push
something to the client there is a cue
for pushing stuff to the client so you
know
if you go through if you're doing stuff
on a mobile device you go through a
tunnel
in a train and you're disconnected from
the server for 30 seconds
a bunch of push events have queued up
the client has a clock
a version number of what it's expecting
for each component on the page
when it reconnects it says okay here's
the components that are that are
expecting potential push information
here is the vector clock for each
component give me anything that's newer
than the vector clock
and so if there's nothing newer than the
vector clock we have a nice
long pole and if there's something newer
than the vector clock the http
request is satisfied immediately the
changes are applied to each of the
components on the page
and then the http request is reopened so
you know push how do we do that it used
to be kind of hard
with to do comet because you'd have to
have a long pole you'd have to have a
bunch of the correct long pole semantics
which i kind of alluded to just a minute
ago
it's marginally easier with websockets
but at the end of the day you're still
crossing the web
you're still crossing address-based
boundaries so you have to deal with a
lot of the crossing address-based
boundary issues
so let me dive into lift let's see how
am i doing time-wise
so darn i'm halfway done i've got to
talk faster
so it's my scala libraries i started
building them about six and a half years
ago
they are the most mature best maintained
libraries in scala land
why do i say this because we have a much
better continuous build and test
environment
we have better cross builds than any of
the other libraries
lyft in addition to being a web
framework does actors and futures and
monads and json and a whole bunch of
other stuff
but we mostly don't publish that because
or publicize that because
people associate it with a web framework
and we tried to change the brand once
and didn't work so
but we do have the best server push in
the industry
so we have ajax which is a single
channel
so even though you might have multiple
ajax requests coming from the browser to
the server
they're all enqueued and they're only
sent over a single http channel
why do we do this to avoid browse uh to
avoid
session or connection starvation the the
server push is a single http long pole
even though you might have 20 components
on the page they're all multiplexed over
a single http connection
it i built lyft in the era of ie6 and it
worked well to do multiplayer games and
ie6
which is good um and in lyft
the server is mostly cognizant of http
which
back set the six and a half seven years
ago was the right way to go
today is absolutely the wrong way to go
between angular and knockout
don't ever let your you know mothers
don't let your children write http on
the server
um okay it didn't quite wasn't quite as
funny as i'd hoped
so lift three i'm making it more data
focused
so the server knows a lot more about the
data and a lot less about the page
because you know that's the way the
world is going and quite frankly
um well it's just a smart way to go
but interestingly as we've been making
the transition to a much more data
centric
model there's been no no change at all
to the underlying transport
so the underlying way that lift
communicates from a browser
to the server or from the server to the
browser has not changed
since um we've been going for a more
data centric model
which actually makes me super duper
ultra mega happy because it's like okay
we at least got one thing right um so
let me get into chat and i'll show you a
demo of the chat
stuff let me go over to my browser so
here's my lyft chat and i can go
hello world and click on the chat button
and our browser updates and if we go
over to our other
browser we can see that
both of our browsers are updating
chatting back and forth
and you know one of lift's nice things
is you can
[Music]
do the wrong thing and the right thing
happens
so let's go look through some of the
code that makes that happen
so on the server side we're actually
defining
we're creating two different endpoints
lift lift 3 has this thing called
streaming promises
so what you do is you create an endpoint
in the browser the
javascript in the browser can call
one of these functions when it calls one
of these functions it will get a
streaming promise back
a streaming promise is a standard
promise except that it can be fulfilled
the then function can be called multiple
times
and so we do is we
say the start function will take a
string as a parameter and one of the
nice things about having
a well-typed language like scala is
we say oh okay when we get our data blob
back from the browser
we're going to try to unmarshal it as a
string
and you can also unmarshal it to case
classes because lyft json
does particularly nice marshalling and
unmarshaling to and from case classes
and we will invoke the function
pushystream.stream
to generate our streaming promise back
to the browser
and when we get a chat when the chat
function is called
it takes a string as a parameter as well
and we will push
that data into pushy stream and then
we'll just return an empty stream
which basically says okay i don't care
what you know you
you'll have the end function called on
your
client side stream so let's look at
pushy stream for a minute
it's an object by the way don't do this
in the real world it consumes threads
and
has all kinds of nasty side effects but
we have a stream
which in scala land is basically a
it's an unbounded collection that
will block and wait until new
elements are added to it so we basically
continually update the stream by trying
to take
from a linked blocking queue so if
there's nothing a link blocking queue we
won't be able to take anything
once something gets added to the link
blocking queue it gets appended to the
end of the stream
so this is the entirety of the server
side
on the client we have some html it's all
angularjs
so we basically say repeat x in chats
and we create an li for each of the chat
elements that we have
in our controller and we have
a model line so that what that does is
that actually creates
an input field associates it with the
model element line
and when we click on our button it calls
the send function
boom that's it and
our angular controller looks like okay
our chats are an array we see the array
with the string welcome
our line is a blank string
the send function basically calls our
server funcs.chat
which was populated from the server with
the line and then resets the line to
blank so you click on the send button
it sends the message on off and then
resets the line to blank
and we do the start thing and for each
of our messages received from the
server we basically
push the new message the new new chat
line
into chats and what winds up happening
is angularjs
because it's got two-way i hate using
the phrase mvc
um two-way mvc you wind up
basically updating your array the screen
is redrawn
the stuff that's the html is redrawn to
reflect the new
value and the user sees their chat
element
so that's it so we didn't have to really
think a lot about the vagaries
of either how we're pushing data
how we're making our cross address base
call
in from the browser to lyft
to our lift chat application nor are we
thinking much about how we're
satisfying our promise
of the chats but we know that when as
the promise is satisfied as the new
elements are
brought into the stream we just get them
so that's lift what's plu so
they're who here has played colossal
caves adventure
a hollow voice says pleu
it was a very not taken word on the
internet
you know not taking words or
plus i used to play colossal caves
adventures for
hours on end i actually had a hand-drawn
map
of the colossal kid wasting time
um the two things i'm doing with with
plu are having a purely angularjs
focused
um framework so basically
it's closure script enclosure but
i don't care about the dom i don't want
to know about html
all i care about in plu is data now the
other thing that i care about in plu
the other thing i care about is not just
pushing data from the client
from the server to the client or taking
data from the client to the server but i
also
care about doing being able to do
analysis of data
so being able to say okay you've got
data on your back end
whether it's in a hadoop cluster
or whether it's on a distributed across
file systems on 30 different machines
i want to be able to take and condense
that information
and present it into the browser in a
unified way
so that the users are you the the
business users the business logic is
identical semantics
whether you're dealing with the stuff on
the back end or whether you're playing
with your data in the browser
and you're never going across http and
by the way you know you can do a couple
hundred thousand rows of data in a
in a browser today in firefox or chrome
i mean the the javascript optimizers are
so good
that they can like look you know you've
got a hundred thousand rows of data
that's identical
you get a very efficient c data
structure that represents those
you've got um a bunch of business logic
that's run over and over again
that'll be jitted it'll be fast so it's
really really really cool
what can be done in the browser today um
so the other thing is who here went to
rich's core async talk
um so core async is all about messages
between two end points and rich had this
uh visual of like a uh
conveyor belt you know you put something
on the conveyor belt
and then something else takes it off the
conveyor belt and does something with it
and core async is a conveyor belt so
what it just does is it disconnects
the guys that are putting stuff on the
conveyor belt from the folks that are
taking stuff
off the conveyor belt and the thing for
me
is that core async you know being able
to put something on the conveyor belt
and then having something else take it
off the conveyor belt
should be across address spaces as well
as being inside address spaces
so you're making a core async call it
has enough of a notion that you're doing
something that's
not going to return immediately not
going to be part of your call stack
that it's not rmi-ish
but it also has the nice semantics of
it's going to happen in the future and
if i pass a channel
and wait for a response on the channel
that i pass i'll get an answer or if i'm
smart i'll do an alt and i'll either get
an answer or a timeout
which is you know kind of the right way
of doing things
um and it can be synchronous or
asynchronous send
and receive um and i'm using it as a
substrate for blue
so getting back to our chat example let
me show you the
um let me show you the blue chat example
so hello world
send and we go over to our chrome
example and
we get howdy and you know basically the
same
the same thing that we just saw in the
lift example
except this time it's in pure closure
there's no javascript to be seen
um the html is actually identical so i'm
not going to show that
this is a closure script i uh
liberally borrowed from a library called
clang which is the closure
angular bridge thingy and you know
mucked with it a little bit by the way
does anybody know if the clang
author is here because i'd like to buy
him a beer he's awesome um
so we do is we set our scope for chats
to
a javascript version of an array we set
our line to a string
we create our scope we create our send
function
and we capture the message which is the
current line
and we capture it because when you go
into a go block
enclosure that's going to happen some
other time
and in the next line over here
we're actually setting the um we're
setting the line variable
the line property back to zero uh back
to blank so we don't know whether this
go block is going to
um occur before or after so before we
enter the go block we want to
capture our variable into
a message and then we send to our server
channel
a message that contains message okay
pretty much the same thing that we saw
in in the lift example except it's a
little bit more
data-e because we're telling what kind
of message we're sending rather than
just sending a string
and for those of you who are in the
pedestal
presentation just before mine uh the
pedestal guy was basically
um he had a verb object-y
kind of message format that he's going
to be standardizing on and i'll probably
liberally borrow from that as well
because well you know
that's what we open source guys do uh
the other thing that we're going to do
is we're going to create our own local
channel called rc
our receive channel we're going to send
to our server
a message to add rc to the list of
listeners to the list of channels that
care about messages
and then we're going to hang out here in
wall true forever
we're going to get chats from the server
and within the scope
of angular we basically when you update
angular variables or variables that
angular is watching you want to say that
you're going to do it within their scope
so they know to watch for the changes
and when they watch the changes then
they update the ui for us
we're going to grab our chat within the
scope we're going for each of the chats
we're going to push the chat into our
array our javascript array and boom
we're done
and so what this does is updates our
array and
angular does its magic and it redraws
and
the nice thing is that we haven't had to
cross a language barrier here
we haven't had to do the mental shift
of okay i was doing scala or closure
or java or ruby and now i have to do
javascript
and you know it's just there's there's a
cost at least for my brain
of making that shift um closurescript is
absolutely beautiful because you don't
have to worry about
the making that shift mentally
the other thing that's really nice is
your data structures are the same
so we created a data structure over here
it gets serialized
and it gets sent over and the one bit of
thing that i had to add to actually make
this work
to get it across the http boundary is i
had to
create a serialization routine for
channels so if you have a channel and
you want to
and you send it across the serialization
boundary what it does is it creates a
guide
for that channel um if if the channel is
a local channel it creates a good for
the channel
and stores a guide locally and then it
sends the guide over
to the other side when the other side
deserializes
the other side says oh i have a thing
that should be a channel i'm going to
create a channel proxy on my side
and so whenever somebody sends something
to channel proxy i'm going to create a
message
that goes over the pipe that gets pushed
over the pipe the other way
and the channel on the other side will
then receive that message
and do its appropriate thing so we have
the
the magic rich hickey conveyor belt
thing going both ways and the only thing
is that there's like
a little x-ray machine that goes oh
you're a channel in this thing that i'm
serializing
and therefore i'm going to treat you a
little bit differently i'm going to make
your bites look a little bit different
and oh when i have that channel come
back across
oh it's a channel that i recognize so
i'll just put that into the
serialized message and so it's the same
data structure on both sides it's a
channel on both sides
except it's a good on the wire
so what does our server look like well
while true
we listen for our server channel if we
have an ad message
we append to our listeners
and we send our listeners all of our
chat messages
and if we have a chat message then we
um add the chat message to the end of
our list of chat messages
and for all of our listeners we send the
message back to them
boom that's it so you know we're not
thinking about anything other than
sending the messages
to this channel and the interesting
thing is that i didn't have the cross
http thing working
when i first did this demo so all this
code was actually living
on in the browser so it's all in closure
script i was able to
fully debug the closure script code and
literally
move the closure script code from the
server block
um from the client block to the server
block and it functioned the same way
because it was
a channel and i'm just serializing data
and sending it across the channel
and the fact the channel was in a
different address space didn't really
matter
which is pretty darn cool now i haven't
got i haven't quite figured out how to
do it um
send failures or receive failures yet
but that's kind of
bubbling around in my brain to say okay
you know what happens when we've
we've tried to retry this thing and that
sort of thing
how do we notify the channel overlords
that there has been a failure i don't
know that one yet but i will get there
so where are my time wise okay i've got
a few minutes
and i'm going to show you the
spreadsheet nader r using the high
institutions
voice the spreadsheet inator it will
allow me to take over all the business
logic in the tri-state area
good i got a laugh out of that one
people didn't run for the doors
so uh
you'll see that we have a grid here
and i'm going to basically make a copy
of the grid or
fork the grid and one of the things you
can see is that if i change
data in the top part of the grid see if
i
ah that was the heinz doofenshmirtz ah
how did that happen at least it was uh
going to the new york times
so you know i changed my age to uh
yeah 35. yeah that's a ticket and you'll
see that the grid
updates okay that's pretty cool but what
happens if we want to add business logic
here let's let's say we want to do some
calculations so
right what we do is we say our age is
actually
we'll subtract 10 years from our age
and click on call and so what this does
is this actually
whoa right
because subtraction is not commutative
so we basically subtract 10 from all of
the ages
okay that's pretty cool and you know
let's uh
let's make sure that our
name is really important so to uppercase
hello oh to uppercase
no wonder
so basically what we've done is we've
taken
our source data and we've run a series
of transformations on the source data
so we've transformed it by saying yeah
we want an age column
and we want a name column and the nifty
thing about what's going on here
is this is actually all um clojurescript
i actually did some nifty stuff to
basically say okay because data
is also because my code is data i'm
going to add a couple of semantics
to my flavor of plu closure script
to say if you have a colon
[Music]
if you basically have a keyword here
we're just going to run
this function and create the column for
that keyword
and i also replace the percent with
a with it as a
well i couldn't get percent working
sorry um anyway so you know
basically what we've done is uh we send
this over to the server the server sends
back
javascript and that's the last time the
server knows about any of the changes
so we make changes up here
so if we change our if we change my age
back to
um
yeah sorry
so focus issue focus must focus
um
so when we change my age here to
you know i have my birthday so i turned
50
and oh interesting oh yeah so it worked
so you know we basically
changed my age from um
50 to 40. we subtracted from my age you
know there's also some nifty stuff that
we can do here we can say
um colon total
age is sum
and this will give us a total of all the
ages down at the bottom
we can also say
colon hash filter
and what are we going to filter on we're
going to say
um
age two number
is greater than
eight
oops
oh yeah thank you
that didn't work well it worked it
worked in the hotel room
but the nifty thing is that we we do the
one round trip to the server because um
closurescript is not yet self-hosting
and
we then get a blob of javascript back
and the blob of javascript is then
applied for each of the
changes that are made to the upper grid
the same javascript is applied to the
lower grid to
create the resulting grid and the really
nice thing there is that you know you
you're not doing your computation you're
not moving
your computation or your data around
the server note the thing that generates
the javascript
from the closure script no longer has to
know about your data
so you can move your program as
javascript
around your network and a program is
javascript is you know a couple hundred
k
compressed a lot less so it's a lot
easier to move that around your network
apply it to a bunch of data and then
pull the applied data into some place
where you can
coalesce it anyway so that's uh that's
it let me go back and
do my last slide which is any questions
by the way that's my dog archer he's the
friendliest dog in the world
in the back
[Music]
how does it compare with single
i have no idea what signal r is so i
can't tell you
sorry okay thanks a lot guys
sorry for going over
you